now to the newest flood of layoffs in
the tech World meta the parent company
of Facebook sent emails to 11 000
employees yesterday telling them they no
longer have their jobs workers heard a
personal apology from CEO Mark
Zuckerberg on this video that was
obtained by NBC News
I want to say you know up front
uh that I take full responsibility for
this decision
meta joins more than 30 other tech
companies that have laid off employees
this month alone Carter Evans has more
on the shock waves that are that is
hitting silicon Valley's Workforce
I pulled up my phone couldn't log into
work chat couldn't log into our internal
sites Eric Trevi stunned by an early
morning email from meta struggled to
break the surprise news to his pregnant
wife I was like looking at my phone a
little bit in shock and and she was like
uh did you get laid off just two weeks
before Thanksgiving the father and
engineering manager finds himself part
of a massive 13 reduction in meta's
Workforce I believe the metaverse is the
next chapter for the internet CEO Mark
Zuckerberg bet big on the virtual
reality metaverse last year when tech
companies were flush with cash while
everyone was working from home during
the pandemic these companies like Mata
have had to undo a lot of that hiring to
adjust to the new reality fellow startup
founder Roger Lee tracks Tech layoffs
and says the impact can be far-reaching
50 of the layoffs intact in the US have
come from Silicon Valley the San
Francisco Bay Area these Tech layoffs
which of course will have Ripple effects
for the local economies nearly 75 000
Tech workers across the country have
gotten the act so far this year and with
borrowing costs rising and revenue
falling there is likely more to come so
where Tech goes that's where the rest of
the economy goes employment consultant
Jason Greer says the booming job market
is starting to shift we're seeing a
crunch on Tech but we're probably going
to be having this conversation about
multiple Industries next week if you're
worried that your company is going to
make job cuts
what should you be doing as an employee
you have to protect yourself you better
get your butt back in the office let's
be real it's remote workers they're
getting laid off first and everybody
else second Eric trieby was a remote
worker and today he'll be back online
looking for a new job what's done is
done I just kind of got to charge
forward got to provide for for my family
for CBS mornings Carter Evans Los
Angeles